Pocahontas was the first single from the
debut album by own in my County right
within a few weeks on the Internet the
video was viewed nearly 2 million times
like many of the Bands songs this one is
intensely personal
so let us hope team eyes the main theme
is definitely that sometimes
relationships don't break up when love
is gone but when it can no longer be
expressed and that can cause enormous
pain this pain is the subject of
Pocahontas the name on in my contour I'd
may be a mouthful but even so people are
talking about them all over Germany the
name comes from the surnames of the
three founding members I'm Christopher
Alan there's Henning my and Severin
Katherine and Martha joined up a bit
later so we couldn't fit him into the
band's name
Kristopher hemming and Severn are school
chums in 2011 after they graduated high
school they started playing in the
streets of their hometown Kelowna at
first they covered English tunes but
soon began writing their own I do think
busking gave us quite a lot musically
that is in terms of how we handle our
instruments we all learned our
instruments together finding our music
in terms of genres is hard but there's
no problem describing it in terms of
values I think for instance handmade is
an important concept we don't use any
pcs we play genuine instruments
what this band expresses through their
German lyrics is also genuine and very
down-to-earth that has struck a chord
and on and my contour I'd are swiftly
collecting fans also through the
internet soon they'll be playing in
larger venues in other cities and
festivals but for now they depend
entirely on one another this
do-it-yourself principle is very
important to us because we wanted to try
everything out the traditional
management tasks the booking etc we did
our own shipping and we've been writing
our own songs a friend shoots and cuts
the band's music videos before some
severe barefoot at the piano has
collected some 10 million YouTube hits
so far in 2015 they want a German web
video award for their song about falling
out of love you write songs like that
when you want to get your feelings
sorted out I'm sure that songs are the
most beautiful when they are absolutely
necessary
in August 2015 they signed on to a major
record label and they'll soon be going
on tour with their debut album Alice
Nick's concretist it's already sold out
a new experience for a next street band
play a couple of cool festivals and a
few really big performances so everybody
who wants to come to a concert can and
then will play a couple of smaller gigs
so we can get really close to the
audience 2016 promises to be on in my
counter rights year the big question is
will success change